if you see joe on emily in paris watch
out
oh my god
[Music]
we are just a nice normal neighbors next
door we are a team
the best team penn joe survives it's the
deadliest season yet but he escapes to
paris were you shocked or what was your
reaction to him still being alive and
what do you think the fans will react
like this season will they still be so
in love with him i was not surprised i
know how long i'm contracted for
and how long is that
and it's uh there's an embargo on that
information will fans still be in love
with him probably they gotta be they
gotta be right i'll search the world if
i have to
i will find
you
penn we have a funny question for you or
maybe it's realistic i don't know joe
escapes to paris emily in paris is also
on netflix what are the chances that we
see a crossover and we see joe becoming
obsessed with emily like should lily
collins be worried who told you
i think if we crossed over it means one
show is getting
cancelled we don't want that we don't
want that if you see joe on emily in
paris watch out
oh my god
why does everybody think i'm impulsive
you are not making me kill anyone
victoria you die in quite a unique way
how did you feel about the way love dies
and her journey this season you know if
you're gonna go
you want it to be unique
yeah you know it was definitely really
um
sad and troubling and tragic the way it
all goes down but i also you know knew i
was going to die so it wasn't surprising
it was it was surprising to see exactly
how did you want more of love or was it
her time that is not my decision well i
don't like that story well she's
supposed to be a soul mate you know i
don't know i was like maybe she escaped
somewhere else we could see her again in
the future but no but no something's
going on you're always distracted are
you okay you look paler than usual well
what would you like to see for season
four what are your hopes for joe i don't
know you know i mean it's not up to me
because i think like i've gotten as far
as a viewer will get by the end of this
season joe is a device that's like fun
to apply to new situations so the fact
that people yet haven't seen him be a
dad and and be married i think is and be
in the suburbs as well like some kind of
domesticity i think people are really
gonna love that and beyond that well
first you gotta get to the end uh to
even consider season four and i don't
talk to the producers
what could go wrong
[Music]
you